[Music]
[Music]
more or less annual event in the
Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics which was made possible by
the quit the questa Malik major mr.
Gartner
it's an annual lecture on history of
aerospace a garden was a graduate of
class of 98 we should not have to
distinguish but say 1898
century as best I can figure out he was
basically a buddy of mine suckers is
that right does anyone remember this one
super state that have this network of
buddies who were influential and being
at money as the huge that comes across
and Gardner was one of them he was they
published a magazine for a number of
years called aviation and aeronautical
engineering he was a decorated officer
aviation officer World War one and
he was fun that allows he
of this lecture
which is a prestigious list of lectures
I'll just read a few off of the previous
lectures Sikorsky Doolittle Sperry Auto
Copland the - Taylor's Nate silverstein
dr. hans von alcohol bill Sears Earhart
Newman T Wilson Neil Armstrong and Bob
Siemens and most recently renamed Miller
and we're indeed honored today to have
one of our alumnus Joe Gavin not only
alumnus very active supporter of the
department Joe received his SP in 1941 a
member of the famous class of 41 it
included Jimmy Maher
a few other people who were quite active
are who else is in the classical
long time ago 55 years ago he was in the
Naval Reserve and served in the Bureau
of Aeronautics during World War two
it was a project officer from the Navy's
first jet fighter he joined Grumman
after the war and as a design engineer
and he served in many capacities there
including the one in which he will talk
about us today as he was a vice
president and director of the Lunar
Module program during the Apollo era
served there until his retirement in
1885 outside of Grumman he's had a lot
of influence on the nation of the world
a member of the devil a since 1946 which
was before it was to get away in 1982 he
was the president would be our
professional Society
before he's received the NASA
distinguished Public Service Medal and
remember me it's International Academy
of astronautics
was a director of the AAAS and became a
fellow of that evening
and in his spare time he's been active
here at the Institute as a member of the
educational council was the president of
the Alumni Association have served on a
number of visiting committees including
ours his life member of the corporation
and has served on its executive
committee which is succeed a real
powered entity
so I would like to I
in fact to introduce you to give his
address on the technology and
programmatic development of the thank
you
well it's a very considerable honor to
join the group who have given this
lecture it also brings back a rather
strong pang of nostalgia now I have to
explain that it's a little hard to feel
nostalgic about ten years of sheer
desperation because that's about what it
was and I'm just going to hit some of
the high points here and I'll skip some
of the the real difficult times but you
know this program the Apollo program
started as a result I think of the
competition in the Cold War there were
many things that led up to it and I
would suggest that the beginnings of
NASA and the beginnings of Apollo are
worth reading up on because they're
quite complicated in my view one of two
major things mr. Eisenhower decided that
it was going to be a NASA was going to
be an open unclassified agency he
managed to fend off the Air Force who
wanted the job and then of course mr.
Kennedy made the commitment to do it at
the time that he made that commitment
one of his advisors was saying that with
the reliability available in components
at that time that it would take probably
40 landings 40 attempts to make a
successful landing well it turned out
otherwise of course and the credit
really has to go to an awful lot of
people you know I'm here today to tell
you as I remember it about the program
but there are an awful lot of people who
are involved at Grumman and it's
subcontractors at the various NASA
centers
and it's pretty hard to find any group I
think that worked as diligently and as
and as focused a fashion for those 10
years
well now let's get into the slides this
this particular slide is from Apollo 15
as I recall and the reason for showing
it is first of all it is on the lunar
surface and secondly the rover is is in
sight and this the last three lunar
modules had the ability to carry the
rover they had more oxygen more battery
power and could stay longer but let's go
back and see how it started the command
and service module got started but it
was many months later that the decision
was finally made to embrace lunar orbit
rendezvous this was something that John
houbolt promoted and looking back at it
I don't think we would have gotten there
without that concept
so that was finally embraced I think in
July of 62 and then there was a
competition and it was an interesting
competition the Center at Houston asked
20 questions and you had to answer those
20 questions and not over a hundred
pages with print not below a certain
size and the idea was that if you knew
what you were doing it would show in the
answers to those questions well we we
did submit a proposal I'm not sure that
then senior management expected that we
would ever win anything but we had to
have a straw design in order to answer
the questions and this is what we had at
the time now this was a vehicle that was
going to be considerably lighter than
what eventually came out of it and it
had interestingly enough five landing
legs on the premise that if you broke
one it wouldn't tip over the other thing
that's interesting about this is that
there were two docking hatches and we
had reason to believe that that was an
advantage we had a helicopter like cabin
that didn't last long but the idea of
good visibility was there and I'll show
you and this shows that there was an
after equipment bag well we did have an
after Clinton Bay it didn't quite look
like that and then we'll jump right away
to what finally came out and this is
taken from Apollo nine the flight test
and Earth orbit and it's really upside
down but it's easier to understand this
way and here you can see the probes on
the landing gear there was great concern
that the dust on the surface the
obscure things to the point where you
needed some mechanical indication of
landing this also shows the the exhaust
bail of the descent engine and the
rather massive insulation around it up
at the top is the rendezvous radar there
was a flasher here which was the backup
means of rendezvous and in this picture
you really can't see the the two windows
because what we had done in developing
the cockpit arrangement was to turn the
the front of the vehicle inside out and
pull the windows right back to the
astronauts eye now you know we hadn't
been into this contract for more than
three months when we began to understand
what some of the priorities were now
this was a cost-plus incentive fee
contract and the incentives depended on
performance which turned out to be
largely wait schedule and cost well I
think in about three months that came to
us that those things were not equal
performance was clearly number one we do
our best to meet the schedule and I hate
to say this Joe but we we really left
the cost to come third as he well knows
so but that was an important idea and it
took us about two years to firm up the
final design because at the time we were
in the competition we did not know for
example the details of the MIT designed
guidance system and then of course
though there were requirements like a
backup guidance system and so on well
let's go on
this is a I'm not sure which mission
this came from but this is the acid
stage and I picked this slide
particularly to show the rendezvous
radar the front door the the front
docking hatch that we proposed became a
door not a docking hatch and then this
is the asset engine exhaust here and
this gives you a pretty good idea of
where the propellant tanks for the acid
engine were it also shows clearly the
the quad reaction control thrusters
there were four on each of the four
corners of the vehicle it's also pretty
clear that this is not a very
aerodynamic vehicle you know to a group
of airplane designers this was a real
awakening that we did not have to worry
about conventional aerodynamics and it
became very utilitarian in the parents
and only its designers could love it
now at the time that we started not much
was known about the lunar surface in
fact there was a a well-known
astrophysicist from Cornell who said
look there's going to be 10 meters of
impalpable dust and not only will you
sink into it but electrostatically it's
going to swarm right up over the vehicle
well I think he told me that in 1965 by
which time we were reasonably committed
to the design and we didn't buy it and
fortunately he was wrong but we did we
did have a pretty conservative approach
to landing as you can see by reading
some of these things and you know
vertical 10 feet per second is a pretty
good jolt now if you land on an aircraft
carrier you worry about maybe 20 feet
per second but for a land-based airplane
that's not too unreasonable now - but
since we didn't know about the the
surface we made some very broad
assumptions we assumed everything from
landing on the equivalent of ice to
landing in for small craters ideally
located to trap all four landing gears
and we landed with various pitching
motions rolling motions going motions
uphill downhill and 400 runs later we
thought we had conservatively surrounded
this problem and as it turned out much
later we probably had over designed
now one of the things that that occurred
duelist not at the very beginning but
you know into it a few months was that
this vehicle only has to make one
landing now that's a revelation to to
somebody who's been designing airplanes
and so we decided that well this is the
the tip-over condition that we worried
about so the shop the shock absorbing
material is honeycomb aluminum honeycomb
and a billet and it's good for one
landing it will take the shock and eat
up the energy it does not rebound and
you can't use it the second time but of
course we're not using it a second time
now we in conventional aircraft fashion
ransom drop tests as soon as we had a
vehicle to drop and we hoisted up in the
hangar and got all the conditions just
right let it go and it came down with a
crash that was absolutely frightening
because all of the gauges in this
machine were much lighter than anything
we had experienced in aircraft and I'm
going to say a little bit about that
later that it made a terrible noise and
it made us so worried at a later date
about the flexibility that much later we
insisted on a drop test where we had all
of the wiring and electronics in the
vehicle to see whether the flexibility
of the vehicle would interfere with the
the electrical systems actually we
didn't find any electrical systems
system problems but we did find one
small mechanical problem that we had to
fix
now I'll add a few more points about the
landing gear we provided a a the ability
to absorb something like 30 inches of
travel in the landing gear I don't think
any of the actual landings used more
than 3 inches and by the time we we got
to this point we knew a little bit more
about the lunar surface the astronauts
had spent a lot of time in the simulator
figuring out how to fly it and what they
really wound up doing was to set a known
rate of descent on the autopilot and
then flied the Machine manually in the
other planes and that worked very well
and I think as a conclusion we could say
the landing gear was somewhat over
designed but this also shows one other
thing it shows that as ample clearance
between the descent rocket engine
exhaust bail and the surface and this
became critical later when we added the
lunar rover and the extended Stay time
provisions because we then had a heavier
vehicle and in order to get there with
the same amount of propellant we had to
extend this bail a few inches and it
turned out that that that was would work
and was acceptable and and that's what
we did now the other thing that came out
of these landings is that unlike what
happens on the ground on earth here when
a vertical landing machine comes down
you have dust that starts out sideways
and then pretty soon you have billows
coming up because of the interaction
with the atmosphere along the moon there
is no atmosphere and what seems to
happen is that the dust takes off
horizontally and just goes out of the
picture so that the dust that we worried
about earlier wasn't that
much of a problem now one of our worst
problems it was with us every day for 10
years was the tendency of the vehicle to
grow and I think the significant point
is from about here when the design was
finally pretty much finalized and then
we had to wait growth then we had a huge
effort huge and numbers of man-hours to
squeeze the weight out of it and then
over here in early 67 was the fire at
the Cape and that led to some tests with
a iron monster cabin and a variety of
other things to ensure that fire would
not occur inside the the reduced
pressure but pure oxygen atmosphere in
the cabin and so the weight went back up
again and then of course this represents
the addition of the rover and the
longest a time provisions to give you
some idea and cut the fireproofing
amounted to this is the back of a
circuit breaker panel and we have little
baggies or well we found of course that
the circuit breaker housings themselves
would burn so then what to do so we
created these little baggies that went
around that circuit breaker body and
then all of the other electrical
connections were covered with this
mud-like material I thought I'd never
forget its name but I have and it was a
very extensive redesign and I would say
that
we lost about a year at that point to
continue with the weight story these are
this is a picture of the ascent stage
tanks the historical they're very thin
proportionally they're thinner than
eggshells and they were designed on the
basis of fracture mechanics to be good
for no more than a hundred
pressurisation the propellants were fed
to the engines by pressure the pressure
on twas helium and so every tank had a
pedigree every test that was made was
recorded and we made sure that before it
went off in a on a mission that there
were an ample number of cycles left and
this is a view of the descent stage tank
and this is similarly thin stuff in fact
we did a lot of our testing with referee
fluids in other words fluids that had
the characteristics of the nitrogen
tetroxide and the udmh but which were
not nasty to handle and we did a lot of
the testing with heavy weight tanks when
I received first light weight descent
stage tank
no of course we filled it check the
volume and consternation set in because
it held 26 twenty seconds more
propellant than we had counted on and so
then the question was did somebody make
a mistake well no they hadn't what
happened was that under the weight of
the propellant the tank stretched
and we were very happy to have that
extra 20 seconds with because if you
remember I'm Strong's lat first landing
he hesitated a bit to clear some
boulders that were that he was coming in
on and I think he was down to about 20
seconds at the time he touched down the
rest of us at Mission Control were blue
at that point
and while we're talking about tanks I'll
talk a little bit about one of our other
very major problems which crept up on us
so slowly that we didn't realize how bad
it was going to be but we had leaks now
nitrogen tetroxide is a nasty material
if it finds a small leak the small leak
soon gets to be a bigger leak and and
it's toxic so you really don't want a
leak and we had designed everything so
light and slender that we had leaks
around these ports at the bottom of the
particularly the descent stage tanks and
we we worked hard at this
in fact we wound up changing all the
seals and in fact one of the vehicles
that was already at the Cape had to send
back this whole lower structure so that
we could redo the seals it was a
terribly frustrating affair and we were
looking for leaks that were on the order
of one cubic centimeter per year
pretty small leak with jet fuel you
would never worry about that
well then this is a picture in a final
assembly area but we have an asset stage
that's being supported independently of
the descent stage and it shows you some
of the precautions we took with some of
the thinner gauge materials and some of
these structural gauges say in this
shear web we're really quite thin we got
down to ten thousandths we would Ken
milled out into ten thousandths and keep
the extra thickness around the edges
with it
where the connectors were and we tried
going to double oh eight and then we
counted the number of grains across a
double O 8 section and chickened out we
went to the ten thousands I might add
that weekend milled almost everything
you could think of propellant tubing was
chem milled keeping the original
thickness where the connectors work and
I have I can't offhand say how many
man-hours were expended in trying to
save weight but it was a large number
and it was an endless process now this
is a picture of the of the asset stage
in a sort of a stripped condition you
can see the acid propellant tank you can
see its support out here this is a good
picture of the window which is just
inches from the astronauts eye and you
can also see that we have the tanks
separate tanks for the reaction control
system and that was one system that was
completely redundant we had a set of
tanks on the either side of the machine
and these tanks were
positive expulsion in other words there
was a bladder in them that allowed the
pressure to surely drive the propellant
out and of course we used the reaction
control system not only from the
NuvaRing but to settle the propellant in
the main tanks before a main engine
firing now this is the next step in the
Assembly of the asset stage and for
those of you who are familiar with
airplanes this is an inside-out machine
in other words in an airplane you get
the sleek exterior and then you package
everything inside it as densely as you
can as some people say so that even if
you dropped a broken egg into it it
wouldn't drain through but here we had a
machine that didn't have to be
aerodynamically slick so we built it
inside out much of the wiring practice
much of the equipment we're outside the
pressure vessel and you can see some of
the the wiring here and then on the
outside we were going to have a thermal
shield which also doubled as a
micrometeoroid bumper and that had to be
supported somehow and that led to this
birdcage like affair which supported
this skin now this you might ask well
how come some pipes of shiny and some
parts of black let me just say that a
very extensive thermal analysis was done
because we are trying to minimize the
power necessary in this vehicle to cut
down the the amount of batteries that
had to be carried and the amount also to
cut down the amount of heat that had to
be to put overboard
and this is the result of some tests in
both well analysis as well as tests and
a thermal vacuum chamber this is a
better view of the reaction control
thruster you see there for a similar
quad on each corner of the vehicle one
of the things that was added very late
in the game and which is not on my model
here is this shield which protects the
descent stage from the firing of the
reaction control thruster that's
pointing down this was the result of
some tests fairly late in the program
that were done on the reaction control
thrusters at the man Space Flight Center
this is another view of the final
assembly area this is an asset stage
that is substantially complete at the
front end but hasn't been all put
together on the back end and the reason
for showing this is to show you that the
equipment batteries radios were mounted
on cold rails the cold rails had glycol
circulating in them the glycol heated
water the water went overboard through a
porous plate so that in effect ice was
formed and it sublimed into space and
that was the only way we could get heat
out of the vehicle if we had too much
heat this also shows some of the
paperwork the weight of the vehicle I'm
not sure whether it weighed more than
the paper or not but we had extensive
pedigrees on just about everything you
could think of and
that's a very important thing because
way back in the beginning we worried
about reliability at that time aircraft
experience was not particularly
attractive it didn't give you any great
assurance and one of our people came up
with the idea that there's no such there
should be no such thing as a random
failure if you have something that
doesn't work either a ground test or any
test you ought to be able to find out
what it is and fix it and in the course
of 10 years we had something over 14,000
such anomaly reports and I believe only
22 escaped satisfactory analysis in the
case of those 22 we changed something
anyhow and I think it was this attention
to the nasty little details that made a
difference I I've mentioned tests I
should point out that we couldn't flight
test this vehicle it's made only to fly
in space
we couldn't hot fire it because our
experience with the propellants was that
you really couldn't clean the system
adequately if you used it in other words
the propellants would tend to gum up the
solenoid valves and so forth so each
vehicle that was launched from Cape
Kennedy was an unused untested vehicle
in every sense except electrically we
were able to do a rather thorough job in
electrical check out but it did lead to
the prior the process of setting up a
very complex and I should tell you
steadily evolving ground test system so
that we could assure ourselves that
the equipment we were getting was good
that it would work after it was in the
vehicle and so on and so forth the now
this is a photo from the final assembly
area again showing a complete vehicle
except the landing gear here and the
same thing here and the point here is
simply that we were working toward a
three-month on center launch schedule so
we had to have these vehicles coming
along fairly regularly now this this
photograph shows the descent stage after
the landing gear is on the principle
reason for showing this is that we had a
rather elaborate blanket of insulation
there to protect the descent stage when
the asset stage took off we tried to run
some tests in the vacuum chambers that
NASA had at White Sands and we could run
short bursts at different levels of
separation but we had no way of running
a truly dynamic test and in fact we
never really knew what happened until
the very last mission when the TV camera
on the rover was aimed at the take off
and while this is a still a lot of stuff
went flying out sideways from that
insulation blanket but the the vehicle
just pops up a set stage pops up now I
should point out that we have a
fly-by-wire vertical takeoff and
vertical
landing machine in the landing condition
it's like a transport because it's heavy
and when it gets back to dock with the
command module it's like a fighter
because it's gone through a ten-to-one
reduction and wait I've mentioned people
earlier and what I've said but it's
impossible to do credit to all the
people that were involved or for that
matter all the families that are
involved we worked a lot of people very
very hard and this is the checkout group
at the Cape and I'll read this for you
this is for the last mission this may be
our last but it will be our best and by
that they meant fewer anomalies to clean
up and of course the lunar module did
work and I think that I'd like to use
the view graph now for a minute we can
turn off the slides and talk a little
bit about something that I fell into by
accident namely management this is a
program organization chart something
that our customer really wanted they
wanted to know who was doing what and we
put this together now the trouble of
this is that this is a static chart it
suggests that all of the people at one
level are equal and I've sometimes
thought that an organization chart
should look like a slowly swirling
galaxy of stars some that are
brightening and some that are dimming
because the rolls tend to change as time
goes by the other thing that I would
point out is that these people never
admitted that they were on the third
level Grauman had a I think of peculiar
culture certainly in the time that I was
there in that everybody looked at the
company as my company and they were not
adverse to calling anybody up to tell
them what should be done differently or
what was going on and it led to a
certain amount of confusion sometimes
but the word got around very quickly so
and I will say that for many years the
company never had an organization chart
Roy Drummond founded the company was
agin it though he didn't have it for
many years the other thing that I would
point out here is how the manpower was
expended and there are a couple of
interesting points here we were always
under criticism for running too much
overtime but it's much more effective in
my view to run over time than to try to
add people in certain cases the other
thing we ran into us that these slopes
right in here
I think we're maximum achievable you can
bring people on board a major program
just so fast otherwise you you wind up
with people not being productive in fact
a good argument what happens in major
programs frequently is that the end date
or the the in this case the lunar
landing date was fixed and there's a
tendency for the start date to creep and
of course the effort is to build up as
fast as you can in order to get the job
done this slope right right about here
is seventeen hundred and fifty people
per year
now that's an instantaneous number but
at the real peak we're adding about
3,000 people a year and that comes about
because there's an acceleration involved
and by the time we got here in 265 we
thought we knew what we're doing and
could be bring people on board and this
is particularly true in bringing
subcontractors on board about half of
the effort I went to major
subcontractors and some smaller
subcontractors this gap right here
represents the the effort to fireproof
everything that came after the fire at
the Cape and then you see we resume what
happens here of course is that there are
some things that you can stop and there
are other things that just have to keep
going so you can't really just come down
here somewhere and then of course once
you have reached an Operations
operational stage things go downhill
pretty rapidly
I'd like to make a couple of summary
summary remarks we had the advantage of
a long-term commitment there are not
many programs that have had that kind of
advantage that I give mr. Craig Kennedy
great credit for having the gumption to
stand up and say before this decade is
out and so forth I think it was
important that we recognized our
priorities and in a highly technical
undertaking I think there's no question
in my mind the what you have to do the
job right
if you take shortcuts you pay more you
pay a larger penalty later I mentioned
the idea of no such thing as a random
failure it worked for us some of our
people who likened it to training every
stone on the beach over to see what was
under it it felt that way at times we we
invested a tremendous amount of effort
on the ground
simply because we couldn't flight-test
and some of those ideas went over into
our aircraft experience later on we
found we could save time and effort in
developing aircraft if we did more work
on the ground and didn't try to fly at
the earliest possible date it also
taught us what I called the basic
program dilemma and that is that if
you're going to do something truly
innovative you can't possibly know what
the schedule is and what the cost is
going to be and if conversely you know
precisely what the schedule is and what
the cost is you ought to stop and think
whether it's worth doing
because it may be obsolete before you
start now this is something I think
engineers understand quite well I've had
a terrible time with some congressmen on
that subject the other thing I'd mention
is that in being in in Europe and in
Japan and more recently in China the
impact of Apollo has been greater
overseas than it has been in this
country the American public is pretty
blasé about these things it's assumed
that you know the rocket scientists can
do anything well they almost can but the
American public passes on to something
else but we created a a reputation
overseas that people are still trying to
catch up with and I think this is
something that particularly those of you
who are students should understand that
the Apollo program was a tremendous
sales effort for American technology and
finally last comment a lot of people
talk about systems engineering it means
a lot of things to a lot of people in
some cases it's just a matter of do you
get all the interface signals correct
and so on but I think that anybody who's
associated with designing flying
machines whether they're flying in the
atmosphere or in orbit or out of space
really is faced with doing a superior
job of systems engineering and the
reason is that if you don't do a
superior job the results catastrophic
and wind up on page one and you really
can't afford to have that happen I grew
up as an engineer and a company that was
run founded by a pilot and some years
where
some very senior pilots in the
management and the in the airplane days
would simply bring the pilot back one
way or another and we did that and I
think that if you have that in mind when
you're involved with designing flying
machines that you will do a superior job
of systems engineering now sometimes you
wonder well can you apply that to other
effort well in a selective way you can
those little US Postal Service trucks
you see running around the result of
applying some of the lessons that came
out of this program and that's a whole
nother story so I'll stop there and I'll
be happy to take any questions
[Applause]
well I can certainly tell you that if I
were doing today there's some things I'd
do differently at the time that we
designed the lunar module we were very
restricted on where we could use
solid-state devices in fact all of the
communication gear was made up of
discrete elements and I was certainly
avoid that that was a nightmare getting
enough units that would pass tests I
would also have a digital data bus just
to reduce the miles and miles of wire
that we had we deliberately went to a a
skinnier gauge of wire than is commonly
used in aircraft in order to save weight
and we paid for it because we had ever
so many faults that came about from just
plane handling the bundles of wire so
anything he could do to get rid of the
old-fashioned way of wiring would be an
advantage I think that it's also quite
likely that a lot of the equipment that
we had well supposing we take the MIT
designed guidance some navigation
equipment I think that could all be done
in a miniaturized version today that
would weigh a lot less I'm not sure we'd
had GPS in lunar orbit but I'm sure that
the what we had while it was great for
its time that's something we could do
much better today and that's probably
true of almost all the equipment Larry
not a word no I knew nothing about it
and I think I can safely speak for the
rest of the crew that we knew nothing
about
well you have to recognize that 40 years
ago I was a lot bolder than him today
and so were we all but there were some
lessons learned in simulation in fact
when we built the x29 a the little
airplane that had the forward-swept
wings and the huge negative stability we
treated that in simulation much as we
did the lunar module and the pilot came
back from the first flight and said gee
it flies just like the simulator so
there were some lessons learned during
the lunar module I crashed one of the
simulators several times for very simple
reason if you tried to translate in a
along the surface of the Moon there's no
air resistance so in order to stop you'd
have to fire in the opposite direction
you don't automatically slow down now
that's a thing that is so
counterintuitive that it takes training
to do to do well you were dealing with a
lot of different people
NASA
first of all how did you spend your time
what did you work with well I'll answer
the last one first every problem you
could possibly imagine in the very
beginning there was a certain resentment
among the dyed-in-the-wool
aircraft people that this strange group
had brought home a a contract that was
going to take a lot of the company's
attention and people and reserves so
there was a matter initially of you know
getting the right people and fortunately
I had some excellent support from people
you know like grant Hedrick and from
them senior management and so we did we
did get the right people and of course
we we had to manage quite a number of
somewhat difficult subcontractors Joe
Shea remembers some of those days he and
I had a great debate one time walking
along the street down at the Cape as to
how much visibility the NASA people were
going to have into our subcontractors
and prior policy had been in dealing
with other government agencies is that
we would manage the subcontractors and
that was that we he won his point
finally and we came down to the idea
that NASA would have visibility as to
our relationships with the
subcontractors but they would
communicate to the subcontractors only
through us since we were the prime
contractor and we felt very strong
we had the the responsibility
I'm not sure I've answered that question
adequately but that gives you some idea
yes what do you talk about 10 years in
lost although the most talkative agenda
as a transient stress can you share with
us the memory or two or the hollis for
me well well claude before i get to that
i want to go back to ball there's one
thing I forgot to say and that is that I
was very fortunate in having a had riyal
with whom I had worked for 10 to 15
years so we were we were pretty well
calibrated one to the other and not only
in the in the engineering into things
but I had a number of good acquaintances
amongst the technicians and the foremen
and every day that I was in Bethpage and
not travelling to Houston of some other
guidance lot I'd make it my business to
walk through the manufacturing area on
the test area and talked to the people
who were busy there and it's amazing
what you can learn just by taking an
hour's walk and seeing firsthand what
people are doing and what problems
they're having and some of the problems
are simple I recall one where the
thermostat on the heating system was
stuck and it was too hot and apparently
the foreman had complained nothing had
happened well I made a phone call it got
fixed so you know the problems range all
over the place I'll tell you that we did
occasionally have to send people home
because we discovered that some of them
were punching out at the end of their 10
or 12 hour shift and then coming right
back in and working another few hours
and we we had some people who actually
made themselves ill in the process but
everybody knew what the name of the game
was and NASA did a great thing in having
the astronauts visit the plant oh I
think about every second a third week so
it became a question of we are building
this vehicle for someone we know not for
some agency that is a bunch of
bureaucrats somewhere now back to Claude
well the low point in in some days was
going to Houston to make a report on how
we were doing and having to get up there
and say well we've lost another couple
of weeks and it's not easy but you know
that's the way things were and we did
what we had to I
speaking of Houston I remember one such
meeting where one of the fellows who was
involved in a navigation guidance group
was suffering from an earache and I
thought I had arranged it so that he
wouldn't go on that trip but he went
anyhow and he was under medication and
he got up to the podium to talk about
what they were doing and he was so
relaxed from the medication that he
created us sensational impressions
but he knew what he was talking about he
got away with that and afterwards
somebody asked me what is he on but but
that was the kind of spirit that we had
in the group and gives you a couple of
ideas of what went on Earl
well that's a hard question to answer
the rule because you see I never became
an expert at anything but I do remember
very clearly professor Joe Newell who
taught structures and who was a very
conservative man and when he went to
Washington he took the train and that
made a great impression a great
impression yes when you comment it on
some of the things that might have
transitioned on maybe the success and
failures of translating the system into
the well the the question in case you
didn't hear it back there was we were
able to translate some of the systems
engineering aspects of handling the lamb
back into the aircraft business well you
have to realize that we took what we had
learned in the aircraft business and
used it in the lamb and then of course
we had on-the-job training because we
ran into so many difficulties and it is
true that we didn't we did sharpen up
the the aircraft business a bit after we
space cadets took it over we instituted
formal preflight reviews now they always
had been some sort of review prior to
flying a new airplane but nothing like
what NASA had taught us to do so we
introduced that
we that stands out in mine and the
simulation that in the simulation of the
two big things you see at the time we
were involved in seeing aircraft that
were very highly well had a lot of
electronics in them and where things
like crosstalk and mutual interference
had really been worked on very very hard
so well we did also introduced the the
matter of certifying the people who
could open a connection now the with all
those with all those prongs and a and a
plug it takes real skill to avoid
damaging it and that helped but I think
that some of the aircraft we were
building at the time were just as
complicated in fact some of them were
more complicated than the lunar module
as I recall the the C the ea-6b had
something like eighty antennas on it so
that was not all that easy either